hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to me so I got myself
some ice water because it was
practically melting in my room because
this story is so hot it's firing
okay let's fire none else you know why I
got a mystery to solve
it's a god damn it the bow sorry sorry
I'm very unprofessional only been
youtubing for a little less than three
years got a bat is that the animal or
the baseball thing
well I'm sports utility thing thingies
also why are there blood prints all over
the walls
what other world did this school get
thrust into can I break the FA's with
this BOTS
that's what I can do can I this is how I
can easily win the game like
instantaneously just get this get the
bat put new Kabam like yeah a jaw like
em oh here we go bat wait good oh my
okay
bat got it in it to win it Vaz get you
something came out of the walls
emergency exit key I'm out of here baby
I got the key I'm good to go I think
maybe I'm just gonna wield this bat for
various reasons before anyone can come
creeping up on me so is this game linked
with mad father in some way and if you
haven't seen mad father I highly
recommend it's very good
RBG [ __ ] so my aunt flora I am another
Hugh we have never met but that is our
fate regardless I've been watching over
you thanks author Samantha didn't know
there was anyone else named Samantha I
thought my parents were just really
cruel to me my great parent markiplier
up in the sky he named me thusly
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa I saw that okay
hi
I got a bat alright why why are you
doing this why are you doing that I can
okay sauce cut some Mario 64
always okay
go thank you this mr. sodas Journal blue
will be banging I'm glad I have that
there's someone in the locker yeah look
in Wow oh hi
oh hey teacher pant pant
thank goodness I'm beat I passed out
after that quake and I woke up locked in
a locker naturally it's designed not to
be open from the inside of course
naturally school looks odd I'm going to
look around and get totally ripped apart
by demon spirits teacher it's dangerous
air whatever he'll learn
he went is he going to be okay ooh I
thought that was actually something
dangerous so it's gonna kill me uh
random banging is not you can now use a
warp function okay hello miss library
you give you to you in the student
council room uh hey hi I'm Samantha or
miss library oh you remember my name
I'm so glad uh how many years has it
been since I've talked to anyone you
were just talking to the principal huh
Samantha please be my friend please be
my friend uh already oh you you don't
want it you don't want to be my friend
I'll be your friend of course I will
free Bailey I'm so glad you're my first
friend didn't you miss libraries kind of
awkward though I wanna know your real
name
well then miss Sam ran and ran through
please give me an easier name
I want a marvelous name what oh gosh
where's it gonna be well I'm hahaha here
is a longer eyes abyss blocker eye god
damn it
is it Blanc er is it's longer okay so
man's ruin
the balanc are gonna go on an adventure
together this is a wonderful name from
now on call me is it longer also I
picked up a southern accent for no damn
reason
so hah friend that's a good word okay
well I have to be going things to do and
awful Samantha but if you ever run into
trouble please come and visit me it's a
blog who will take Carrie I don't know
how useful I can be but I'll do what I
can to help okay thanks
I'm sorry I find it so funny but I don't
have these opportunities that much and
she's a charming character okay you'll
find items as you progress through the
game you must find these to beat the
game an item like a caramel has no
effect on its own you need to make sure
to equip it once equipped you can use
that item
Rezac ansel kewal exploring the open the
ring command like this is play your item
list move the cursor to the desired item
and press the confirm key to equip to
unequip whatever item you equip do the
same thing on that item again okay I
shall explain the oh god I don't need to
know this I can figure this out I can
figure it out I'm a smartypants I know
unless there's like some hidden
information that I need is there rumor
has it that president Oh need go ara has
hidden a secret password somewhere I
looked all I could find I found nothing
can't that old man do anything other
than save her load Oh someone's coming
awkward wording there hold down the
cancel key to speed through text some
text cannot be skipped okay thanks so
I'm on the lookout for a hidden password
is that the case alright good thing all
this blood is on the walls
you hear moaning from inside is someone
having a good time in there oh oh yes
please hi oh my god I am dead well can't
say I didn't see that one coming
but then again I don't know if that's
gonna be something important later it
might be maybe I need some zombie bait
another student perhaps maybe Thomas
girlfriend or should I say excu all
right what do we have here okay alrighty
then Oh looted oh my god
this is brutal oh I just died straight
up oh okay that fish yeah alright so
don't look back
it's what I'm getting at here oh god
it's even worse it's some creepy
Japanese like schoolyard song
oh god it's locked oh no oh no oh no oh
wait no oh oh oh I know this I have I
have the key I don't know I didn't know
this was odd has the same symbol okay
okay unlock the door okay where am I now
what the hell how does this help me at
all
oh hi kudo kudo don't look too good
how the answer you're hurt are you all
right
a monster got me I tried to run but I
sprained my leg and then he just got
tired and walked away hurts help okay
that voice me Sal kuda can hear her too
Misao is in pain damn Foley I had been
quicker to save me sau Kudo Misao and I
were together since kindergarten we
played together all the time
in middle school I was teased for
playing with a girl so I tried to avoid
me so when I learned me say I was
getting bullied didn't help her and now
I'm sorry miss out sorry I couldn't help
you I'll be there soon
oh god he's dying okay I'm always beside
you so don't cause any more sadness okay
Misa
Oh hack good help of course
dingus dang tutor please huh oh okay
well alrighty then what a bunch of
baloney what a bunch of malarkey
are you kidding me oh yes what is this
call ya'll pull out on me Oh mister man
the hello creepy girl I gotta go talk to
me dying kudo and then just watch him
get run over by a car cuz that's how
this game rules oh man where's rabbit
didn't on the Menem huh bit okay I can't
be too quick cuz it's gonna give me a
log option Oh cack okay kuda got a watch
what Oh important stuff okay Misao came
to meet me now I'll always be together I
love you miss ow
you're mistaken I never liked you at all
now die oh man that's cruel me oh no
miss aha
again with the car that's so cruel this
is awful
okay can't save can't save that can't
save what blew up over that way
car crash I can't go over that way why
nice okay there's no way to go I got
wait maybe huh maybe on his mutilated
corpse I could find it but now I'm
looking at her face it's like that se
peaches Bad News Bears okay so now that
that horrible episode is past what
awaits me next in this delightful game
click oh yes library I don't need a
number and what I need to do is I need
to go save again for some reason
everything wants to kill me in this game
and also why is this one not able to
open up there's got to be something in
there that's important
be wary bla bla bla I want to see it yes
please please okay that's gone gone I'm
still good on time so let's roll forward
roll forward into the deep dark night
and awaits me
ah so I can't go outside a little bit it
just won't do me much good will it oh
did not know I could actually go down
here a boulder is in the way might be
broken with a heavy blow I can't destroy
barehanded I don't even know if not bad
I'll be able to do it but I'll try Wow
okay did not expect that to work
Kabam fix this is some bad oh oh oh oh
it just took the place in my head it's
like a thing from dead space oh my
goodness can I'm gonna wait okay then
I'm gonna give that one more go I'm
gonna try to go to the side quickly
before the end hahahahahahahahahaha
I got your baby
ah there's writing on the wall I seek
blood well
don't know what to do about that okay so
game has saved so what important thing
was down here more writing I thought
this was just like mushrooms alders plus
alders what is what okay alders like
alright never mind screw you so if I
have blood and come back to the well oh
hello
CUDA home kudos Quinn no now CUDA
someone's grave there's no name on na
kuda sacrifice the body or the curse
will never end
okay whose body is that a mannequin
nothing happens
that mean way what does this all mean so
I gotta sacrifice a body all right
whatever there's some strange baloney
I'll tell you what so does everyone
besides me have to die piece of paper
pick it up you're dead no huh
okay alright hi now she looked at me
hard whatever am I gonna do okay
don't pick up the piece of this game is
unintentionally hilarious in a lot of
ways I mean that startled me but still
it's game very good pretty much its game
pretty funny I like it I like it a lot I
really like this game so anyway that's
all for this episode I'm gonna keep
playing this thank you all so much for
watching check out more RPG horror games
that I played again in the description
or in the annotations over there thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see
don't you put your soul to rest that's a
very good scolding you need to really
learn okay ladies let's get one thing
straight this bull it's ugly that dress
oh okay
yeah my feeling where you come from
what